women's rights in america are under
attack
if the court
overturns roe v wade
it will be a direct assault on freedom
on the fundamental right
of self-determination
to which all americans are entitled
roe
protects the right to access abortion
it also protects
a woman's right
to make decisions about what she does
with her own body
but let's talk about what a world
without roe looks like
women in almost half the country
could see their access to abortion
severely limited
in 13 of those states
women would lose access to abortion
immediately and outright
those republican leaders who are trying
to weaponize the use of the law against
women
will we say
how dare they
how dare they tell a woman what she can
do and cannot do with her own body
how dare they
how dare they try to stop her from
determining her own future
how dare they
try to deny women
their rights
and their freedoms
they want to
ban abortion in every state
they want
to bully
anyone
who seeks or provides reproductive
health care
and they want
to criminalize and punish women from
making these decisions
at its core
row recognizes
the fundamental right
to privacy
think about that for a moment
when the right to privacy is attacked
anyone in our country
may face a future
where the government can interfere with
their personal decisions
not just women
anyone
and it has never been more clear
which party
wants to expand our rights
and which party
wants to restrict them
it has never been more clear
[Applause]
it has never been more clear
which party
wants to lead
us
forward
and which party
wants to push us back
if you stand for freedom
for self-determination
for the right to privacy
if you stand
for these principles
stand with us
[Applause]